il reste environ six ou sept minutes
journal et ja que c'est tendu ici dans
le stade olympique était immense ça
dépasse le sport c'était l'événement
planétaire le bceco couloir numéro 3
j'en sûr de pouvoir me rossi on avant le
le sentiment que paris bercy johnson qui
faisait partie johnson attention dans le
couloir numéro 37 ans m
elia bremer tumorales victoire du mans
tél
ces patients s'est empoigné par tour ce
qu'on allait après canada canada canada
s'était arrêtée comme les qui
malheureusement après ça a été
c'est comme la grosse baleine qui a
failli fermer
[Musique]
le critère du matin mon collègue jacques
camirand qui était chef de pupitre assez
grasse il téléphone à nizar gravel la
journée va être longue
il ya une rumeur qui circule c'est l'
agence france-presse qui avait publié en
ce coup puisque c'est quand même assez
étonnant
vous avez une information comme quoi
johnson avait été disqualifié à jouer à
la roulette russe
il a perdu de son père j'ouvre les
rideaux que je voyais candidats une
nouvelle qui se répand comme une traînée
de poudre
je voyais les lumières le danger tous
les flashs
tout le monde se réveiller en même temps
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs c'est un
jour triste pour le sport canadien pour
le canada convenons has been withdrawn
quoi des images de ben johnson il est
introuvable depuis le matin voici les
images à l'aéroport ce matin
[Musique]
je pense que nous et c'est tout aussi
doper l'audience alors johnson est
coupable s'est fait passé c'est le drame
c'est souvent les innocents qui se font
pincer dans mesure où c'est les gens qui
réussissent pas à cacher on savait qu'il
y avait quelque chose qui clochait a tué
son regard juste un peu normal pas de
compétition c'était tellement agressif
j'ai aussi rencontré journaliste afp
il y avait eu le scoop lui du
responsable du laboratoire il le
bonhomme l'avait fait parce que y avait
peur qu'une histoire de chat moi je suis
profondément convaincu que s'ils
savaient pas été de cette rumeur jamais
la nouvelle raison j'étais tellement
gros que le seuil où j'avais aucun
intérêt je suis leur connaît des fois je
me bats
j'étais pas loin de lui je le regarde un
peu de profil j'avais j'avais mal pour
lui c'est quelqu'un qui sûrement ils
doivent heures
j'ai mené sans retourner en arrière puis
le faire kling mais ce pôle est trop
tard